BACKYARD.
MAKE NO MISTAKE FROM CHICAGO TO
SEATTLE TO L.A. TO NEW YORK,
AMERICAN CITIES ARE IN CHAOS.
THE DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE BEEN IN
CHARGE FOR DECADES HAVE FAILED
TO UPHOLD THEIR MOST BASIC AND
FUNDAMENTAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
THAT IS THE SAFETY, THE SECURITY
OF THEIR FELLOW AMERICANS.
HERE IS TODAY’S COVER OF
"THE NEW YORK POST," CRIMES
RAVAGE CITY CALLS OUT FOR HELP.
TO DO SOMETHING.
ACTUALLY, COME, COMRADE
DE BLASIO HAS DONE A LOT OF
THINGS, A LOT OF HORRIBLE THINGS
THAT IS DESTROYING NEW YORK CITY
COSTING MANY LIVES.
THE ANTI-CRIME PLAINCLOTHES
POLICE OFFICERS AND THE NYPD,
THAT UNIT HAS BEEN DISBANDED,
COMPLETELY ELIMINATED THE
EFFECTIVE POLICY THAT WE WOULD
CALL STOP AND FRISK, CUT THE
NYPD BUDGET BY OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN THAT STATE LAWMAKERS
MIGHT FORCE POLICE TO BUY THEIR
OWN PERSONAL INSURANCE FOR
LIABILITY LAWSUITS.
I GUESS MY ONLY ADVICE IF I’M
GOING TO BE A FRIEND TO THE
PEOPLE I LOVE AND FRANKLY ADORE
AND ADMIRE FOR THE SACRIFICE,
SERVICE, AND THE RISK THEY TAKE
FOR ALL OF US I GUESS IF YOU
WERE A COP AND YOU CAN RETIRE,
NOW IS THE TIME.
YOU ARE NEW ON THE JOB, MIGHT
WANT TO THINK ABOUT ANOTHER JOB.
NEW YORK CITY IS BASICALLY
GIVING YOU THE MIDDLE FINGER AND
ALSO MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE TO DO
YOUR JOB TO PROTECT AND SERVE
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
MEANWHILE, HE SIGNED OFF ON THAT
IN THE IDIOTIC BAIL REFORM
POLICY AND IS THE ONE THAT
SIGNED THE BILL THAT ALLOWS
VIOLENT OFFENDERS TO GET OUT OF
JAIL THE EXACT SAME DAY WITHOUT
POSTING A PENNY IN BAIL.
NOTHING WHATSOEVER.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THESE SOFT ON CRIME POLICIES
IS NOW DIRE IN NEW YORK CITY AND
STATE BECOME A IN NEW YORK CITY
ARE UP 30%, THEY ARE UP 118%.
ON MONDAY, A 14-YEAR-OLD WAS
SHOT THREE TIMES IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT ON THE STREETS.
NOW BEFORE I SHOW YOU THE NEXT
TAPE, FAIR WARNING WHAT YOU’RE
ABOUT TO SEE IS EXTREMELY
GRAPHIC AND LOOK AT THIS
HAPPENED OVER THE WEEKEND, A MAN
SHOT DEAD IN THE BRONX IN
NEW YORK WHILE WALKING, SEE THAT
6-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER ACROSS THE
STREET AND YOU SEE THE GUY IN
THE CAR RIGHT THERE, HE POINTS
THE GUN AND ASSASSINATES THAT
MAN IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
HORRIBLE.
POOR GIRL RAN FOR HER LIFE IN
FEAR AND ON SUNDAY, CAPTURED
THIS GUT WRENCHING SCENE, THEY
OPEN A FIRE, KILLED TWO OF THEM
MEN, SEVERELY WOUNDING ANOTHER.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THIS?
YOU ARE ALLOWING THIS TO HAPPEN
AND LET ME TELL YOU WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN NEW YORK IS THE
DIRECT RESULT OF THE FAILED
POLICIES.
WHEN LAWS ARE NOT ENFORCED, WHEN
POLICE BUDGETS ARE SLASHED, WHEN
COPS ARE NOT SUPPORTED, WHEN
CRIMINALS GET OUT OF JAIL
WITHOUT ANY BAIL, CHAOS,
CARNAGE, PREDICTABLY WILL ALWAYS
ENSUE, ALWAYS.
NOT A HARD MATHEMATICAL FORMULA,
AND NOW DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY NO MORE ARGUING THEY
WANT TO COMPLETELY DEFUND AND
DISMANTLE ALL LAW AND ORDER AND
ALL POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
SOCIALIST AND THE SO-CALLED
SQUAD IN CONGRESS JUST UNVEILED
HIS GENIUS BILL TO STRIP POLICE
FUNDING.
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR IS NOW
CALLING FOR THE ENTIRE SYSTEM TO
BE "DISMANTLED."
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM?
GET RID OF EVERY COP, EVERY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL?
WE GO BACK TO THE SIMPLE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION, WHO WILL
YOU COME OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CALL IN AN EMERGENCY AFTER THESE
DEMOCRATS DISMANTLE THE POLICE?
RE-GOING TO CALL?
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN
IF DEMOCRATS GET THEIR WAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU HAVE REACHED THE 911
EMERGENCY LINE, DUE TO DEFUNDING
OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENT, NO ONE
IS HERE TO TAKE YOUR CALL.
LEAVE YOUR NAME AND NUMBER AND
SOMEONE WILL GET BACK TO YOU.
OUR ESTIMATED WAIT TIME IS
CURRENTLY FIVE DAYS.
GOOD-BYE.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENTS AD IS
EXACTLY DEAD ON ACCURATE
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE TRUTH IS
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DEFUND POLICE.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT YOUR
SAFETY OR SECURITY, THEY DON’T
CARE IF YOUR BUSINESS GETS
DILUTED, THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT
OUR SIN, DON’T CARE IF YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD HAS TAKEN OVER BY
VANDALS AND ANARCHISTS, THEY
LIVE BEHIND GATED COMMUNITIES IN
WALLED OFF COMPOUNDS, MANY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PAY FOR THEIR OWN
PRIVATE SECURITY OR EVEN USE
THEIR TAX DOLLARS TO PROTECT
THEM AND SO YEAR AFTER YEAR
DECADE AFTER DECADE, THEY IGNORE
THE VIOLENCE AND MAKE NO MISTAKE
IF DEMOCRATS GET THEIR WAY WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN NEW YORK,
HAPPENING IN CHICAGO, HAPPENING
IN SEATTLE AND IN CALIFORNIA,
THAT WILL BE COMING TO A TEAM
NEAR YOU.
LET’S CALL IT A PREVIEW OF